Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by Doctor Leo Papa. She is
a tendered researcher at the Institute of Science, Cognitive
Mac uh Jan of the San Nacional de La
Research Scientific in France and principal investigator of the
research program, the Temple funded by a European Research
Council starting grant. And today we're talking about social
perception, basically what we pay attention to in other
people and their interactions and the social information we
get from that. So, Doctor Pao, welcome to the
show. It's a big pleasure to everyone.
Thanks for having me.
So when it comes to how we perceive other
people, what are the kinds of things we usually
pay attention to?
So um attention depends on um a number of
things, depends on the salience of the stimuli. So
how salient the stimuli are to our eyes. So
for instance, a bright red object is going to
attract our attention more than a dark small object.
But at the same time, attention also depends on
our internal goals, what we are looking for in
what we see. And so it's a very interesting
balance between the outside world and our internal mental
representation. And uh um so, in the case, when
it comes to people, uh so others on specifics,
um there are uh the first thing that like
the first thing that we attend to are, are
the uh the research in cognitive neuroscience has suggested
that there is a sort of a hierarchy of
the things that we care about first and this
hierarchy goes by eyes, face and then the rest
of the body. So, um but again, like a
what what we we attend first depends on what
we are looking for in the outside world. So
for instance, if we are looking, for instance, for
an object, for an interaction with another person, we
might, we might, we might be attending more the
limbs. So the arms, the hands than the face,
but generally a good, a good summary is that,
you know, the face and eyes come first.
But when we look at other people and will
later on in our conversation, we're going to get
into more detail in terms of, for example, when
people are facing one another or in terms of
how they uh present themselves in relation to 1
to 1 another, what kinds of things we pay
attention to and what kinds of information we get
from those kinds of, let's say interactions? Are there
generally speaking, are there particular kinds of information that
we are looking for? When we perceive other people
in either in isolation or in interaction with others.
Um So, um we pay attention to a lot
of things uh because we, we care about a
lot of things. Uh But uh um we can
uh synthesize these uh um the features that we
care about in two categories. One is uh those
features that help us to understand who is the
other, who the other is, who are you And
the others are the features that uh uh help
us understand what are you doing? So there are
these two aspects of another that we consider very
important for our immediate behavior and also for our
survival. So when we look at another, at another
person, uh we are very efficient, our system, our
visual system is very efficient at extracting a number
of important pieces of information that allow to, for
instance, decide or establish surely the gender, the age,
we have very sensitive to the cues that suggest
the age of our, of the other, the origin,
the race. There are, there is a full line
of research suggesting that there are very subtle ways
in which difference in the race of the others
affect our behavior. Um And uh uh of course,
uh also we can extract information from just the
visual appearance by just looking at the others, we
can start information about the status, for instance, how
dominant the person is in the social hierarchy and
the state. So the mental state, the mood of
the person. There are beautiful experiments showing that just
by looking at the motion pattern. So the way
in which another uh moves we are very accurate
in determining uh uh their emotion, whether it is
happy or sad and so on. And this is,
you know, the category of features that I define
as those that allow us to understand who the
other is. But then there is another set of
features that we are very good at uh processing
and extracting from visual information from just looking at
the others, which are the features that allow us
to understand what the other is up to what
it is about to do. Um And these features
are especially important in the context of social interaction.
So it's very important um to uh observe the
others interacting between each other with each other to
construct a number of features that allow us to
understand. Uh AGAIN, is a role in the society
in a, in a specific context, but also more
generally, um whether a person is uh um in
the, in the social hierarchy above or below the
other person, uh the level of intimacy, the social
distance. Uh And also from the way in which
two interact with each other, we can immediately understand
with a very fine sensitivity to the motion patterns,
the way in which people move and interact with
each other, whether they're having a they are in
a friendly relationship, whether they're sharing the same goal
or they are competing, whether they're helping each other
and so on. All these, all this information comes
out of almost a first glance to the others.
A and B. By the way, uh, you mentioned,
uh, several different things there, like, for example, people's
race or ethnicity, I mean, uh, uh, do we
know to what extent some of the things or
the kinds of informations we, uh, the kind of
information we want to acquire from other people and
the kinds of things and behaviors we pay attention
to. I, if at least to some extent they
are culturally learned. There is, I mean, my pay,
paying attention to one person's ethnicity is something that
I learn culturally to pay attention to or if
all of these things or at least a few
of them, uh, are sort of quote unquote, I
innate. There is even newborns already pay some attention
to some of these features and behaviors. W what
do we know exactly about that?
So that's, um, that's a very interesting question that
has been the subject of, uh, research for decades.
Uh And, uh, of course, there are many unknown,
so many things that we don't know yet. But,
uh, uh, certainly, uh, we can say that humans
are born with, uh, uh, innate, an innate or
at least very early when I say early, I
mean, within hours from birth ability to recognize faces
to detect a specific kind of motion which we
call biological motion. And that's the specific way in
which biological entities moves, that is very different. For
instance, from the mechanical motion. Uh HUMANS are also
born with uh uh a very early capacity to
uh attend to the other side and know where
the others are looking at us. So when we
are being addressed, relative to when the others are
looking somewhere else, and we also have a very
early uh and efficient capacity to follow the other
gaze. So to know that's one of the first
thing, maybe the most important thing that we uh
look at when we process others where they're looking,
which anticipates or predicts what they are going to
do. So if they are looking at me, this
is probably a signal, a very strong signal of
social engagement is looking for social engagement is looking
away, OK, where he or she is looking. So
these are the things that uh infants within hours
or days from birth are very sensitive to. And
uh um we share many of these processes, many
of these mechanisms that make us so efficient in
processing socially relevant stimuli with non human species. Like
we have seen in a similar uh behaviors, very
early behaviors in uh various species of monkeys, but
also in uh uh chickens, for instance, or in
a species that um are farther away from us.
Uh Then there are other aspects as you asked
about the race or the age, there are other
aspects that emerge relatively early. So there are, there
is, for instance, this phenomenon known as the, as
the other race effect, which refers to the um
to the basically very early sensitivity to uh people
or to individuals who are from a different race
than ours. Uh There is something similar, for instance,
in speech perception, this early sensitivity to differentiate between
uh speech sound that are from our native language
and speech sounds that are from another language. For
instance, Indians have some uh uh uh uh sounds,
some phonological sounds that we don't have like the
the we don't have these sounds in our language.
And very early on infants are capable of discriminating
between the sounds of their native language and sounds
from other languages. But this is this kind of,
you know, sensitivity to these more culturally determined differences
um seems to be the result of a learning
process which operates very rapidly again, within months from
birth, infants can make this subtle discrimination. But it's
because when they are born, they are born and
they are immediately immersed in a very rich social
environment. And so they immediately pick up the features
that are typical or their native social environment and
immediately become capable of distinguishing those features that are
very important from their integration in their own society,
from uh features that don't belong to their own,
to their own cultural uh group.
So in my first question, one of the things
you mentioned that people and also infants in this
case, pay lots of attention to is the face,
in particular features of the face, like the eyes.
For example, eye gaze, uh apart from eye gaze,
what are some of the other features of the
face that people tend to pay attention to? And
what kinds of information do we get from that?
Um The uh human ability to process a phase
is impressive. I would say that there is nothing
that uh uh uh there is nothing that is
so efficient, so uh tuned uh uh than the
human ability for face perception. So just by looking
at the face, we, as I said, we are
able to, first of all immediately recognize the identity
and discriminate between the two faces even when there
is a lot of similarity. Um And uh uh
there are uh there are again, two different aspects,
uh two different categories of features that we uh
uh one category is uh uh what allows us
to identify a person. So as I said, to
categorize a person in terms of gender, race, age.
And if we know the person also immediately assign
a name to that person, an identity to that
person. And so immediately retrieve all the, you know,
knowledge and information that we have about that person.
This this is a very rapid, very efficient mechanism.
And then there is another uh family, another set
of features that allows us to uh uh to
establish, to, to, to process the actions of the
face. And in the case of faces, actions uh
are uh manifestation of manifestation of two things. One
is the communication. So by looking at faces, just
the way in which the face move uh moves
is very important for uh speech perception. For we
know that if we have access to the face
of the speaker, our speech processing, so our ability
to process and to understand what the speaker is
saying is much more efficient. And there are a
lot of interesting phenomena that show that in fact,
the facial movements can affect also the acoustic signal,
the acoustic information what we hear. So if I
show him movement of the lips that is not
compatible with the sound that I'm producing, that the
speaker is producing. And there are very nice experiments
that manipulate the mismatch between the lips movement and
and the sound you see that we perceive a
distorted sound, which means that what we see in
the movements of the face affects what we hear.
And also the second, the second type of action
information conveys uh um information about emotions. We know
that uh you know, very, we have a very
rich repertoire of facial uh actions that convey um
as well rich um set of different emotions. And
so these two family like the features to define
who a person is and the features to define
what the the face is doing is trying to
communicate. Um OF course, are tightly related but can
also be dissociated. And when I say dissociated, I
imply that they are actually um features that are
processes in partially different parts of the brain, of
course, very strongly integrated.
So now I would like to ask you about
something very specific that I read about in your
work. What is facing di perception? And does it
relate in any way to face perception?
So um for many uh years, um for many
decades, cognitive neuroscience has studies. Of course, we have
this uh very strong uh and understandable interest uh
for social perception, social cognition, how we understand how
we recognize others. But for many decades, these questions
have been, these questions have been addressed by uh
studying uh the perception of the processing of individual
faces, individual bodies, individual movements. Uh UNTIL uh when
um researchers including myself and the people working with
me uh decided to see uh to study what
happens to all these beautiful mechanism that I've been
talking about uh to process faces, motion bodies. When
instead of seeing one face, one person, you see
two people together, all these um sensitivity, all these
tuning to all these features is preserved or there
is something else that happens and what we have
seen. So the main interesting result that we found
when we started asking this kind of question was
that as I said the faces are very special
to our visual system and to the whole brain
because they are fundamental to understand interact, to recognize
others. But what we saw is that um when
we see instead of one phase, two phases, uh
all these uh very efficient uh uh processing uh
is preserved, particularly one, the others are perceived as
if they are interacting, which means face to face.
So we did a very simple experiment. We, we
were studying, you know, the the efficiency of visual
recognition of multiple bodies. And so we presented the
pairs of bodies in different special configurations. And we
soon realized that subjects were particularly efficient at recognizing
multiple bodies as efficient as they are at recognizing
one face when these two bodies are put face
to face relative to when they are in any
other configuration. And so that was the first insight.
The first in the first uh uh piece of
information that suggests to us that there might be
something really special uh in the brain uh uh
about uh uh the perception of what we call
the facing diet. Now, why the fishing diet? Why
two people face to face would be special to
our visual system? Well, this is an open question
but the intuitive response is that this configuration, when
we put two people face to face, this is
the prototypical configuration of human social interactions. So when
we interact with others, we privilege this face to
face positioning, because this face to face positioning gives
us access to the other side to the others.
Face full face. So we can extract information about
uh emotions. And uh also uh it gives us
access to the whole body. So it's the the
perfect viewpoint to have as much information as possible
from the other. And so to facilitate uh interaction.
And so the idea is that this facial configuration,
these are, these are face to face configuration of
body is so important for our social life and
so redundant. So, recurrent in our social environment that
the human brain has developed a mechanism that make
the processing of these two bodies especially efficient. And
this is confirmed by if we look at the
uh evolutionary psychology literature, uh you know, people have
studied uh how often humans spend, how much time
humans spend in certain, you know, special positioning, special
positions relative to each other. And they have seen
that not just humans, but also monkeys and probably
other species spend uh more than uh the 50%
of their time in social interaction, facing, facing another.
So face to face with another. And most of
the time uh I I uh the most frequent
composition involves two people. So face to face di
adding interaction seems to be uh an important uh
recurrent uh uh structure in our social life in
our social world.
So this is already, I guess one aspect of
studying social sin perception, right? And uh one of
the things associated with that or a concept, I
guess in this case is minimal social sin. So
what is that concept really about? And what can
you study through it?
So it's uh uh it's uh this idea of
minimal. So social scenes refer to what I've just
described. So when we started this research, we wanted
to see to isolate, to get really like we,
we see a lot of interactions, all kind of
uh actions that people perform on each other or
with each other. Uh uh PEOPLE act uh in
uh diets, in groups. So we have crowds of
people doing things together so that the social interaction
that the range of social interactions is possible. Social
interactions is very broad. But we wanted to get
to the minimal unit. What if we if we
remove all the unnecessary features and we get to
the core structure of the social interaction, what remains
and what remains is this uh uh two body
configuration. So this configuration that involves two bodies or
two phases in general, two people, two social agents
facing closely like in special proximity and facing each
other. So and this is this is really like.
So we decided to study this configuration of two
bodies is a facing diet just like we have
studied other objects in visual perception, just like we
have studied faces, we have studied bodies, we have
studied any other object in the world, we consider
this a new object of visual perception. This is
a configuration which is the early rudimentary representation of
a social interaction.
Uh And so, uh we've talked earlier about how
people interpret when they see someone or a di
have of people facing each other. So apart from
facing each other, what are perhaps some of the
other kinds of cues that people take in when
distinguishing between an interacting and a non interacting, died
in crowds, for example.
Yeah. So we have uh again, just like in
the case of face perception, we are now this
is a very recent line of research that is
really considering this new object of social perception, which
is not one body, not one face, not one
action but two people together. And so we are
now discovering all the information that is rapidly extracted
from this stimuli. And so as you said, one
is the relative positioning, what we call the facing
where they are facing each other or not or
they are facing away from each other. But there
are another uh a large family of, of, of
a large set of cues that uh uh we,
we think and research suggests that are really relevant
to process, to initiate the processing of social interaction.
Some of of such cues are, for instance, as
I said, the special proxy, how close in space
to people are uh the touch, whether they are
in contact, they are touching or not. So uh
others are the mimicry, whether you know their body
postures or their facial expression look alike, which means
that which, which is a feature of the social
interaction. When we interact with someone, we tend to
have this automatic mimicry of their behavior. And we
can see from outside when two people are interacting,
they tend to uh imitate themselves, they tend to
coordinate or to synchronize. So, coordinations, synchrony, miry um
distance openness like the typically people that are interacting
and have this posture that is open to each
other. And these are very uh measurable. We can
take, you know, photos of interacting people and really
measure all these things. And this is exactly what
uh um scientists are doing right now. Uh First
of all, to understand which are the the the
the properties, the features of an interaction that we
process, that we extract the uh uh from which
we make is about the social relationship between two
people. But also to understand whether there is a
hierarchy between these things. So what is the relation
between these things? We don't have the answer to
this question yet. But you know, intuitively, 1 may
think that if two people are face to face,
they are probably interacting or this is what our
brain spontaneously. But uh you know, if you start
manipulating the distance, so you increase the distance between
them, probably the effect of facings starts, you know,
diminishing, diminishing. So and it would be interesting to
see at which point, the distance breaks the effect
of facings whether it does it at all. So
basically, this is the kind of questions that we
are now asking to um to, to understand how
because that's the thing. The question is not whether
we understand social interaction and what we understand about
social interaction. Because we do understand social interaction, we
are very, very rapid at you know, understanding what
kind of relation there is between two people just
by looking at these people. And uh we understand
a lot of things, we can extract a lot
of kind of information just by looking at how
two people interact with each other. But the question
that we're trying to answer is how we do
it, how our brain does it. So this is
why it's important to understand. OK, what are the
basic cues that the visual system extracts from the
structure of the input or from what we see
outside that starts this process that then leads to
a full understanding of the social interaction.
And of course, it's very interesting to understand or
know what these basic cues are. I mean, the
basic kinds of things that people pay attention to
in the social scene to perceive and interpret how
people relate to one another and what people are
doing that is socially relevant there. But I I
would imagine that something that is also very interesting
to understand these uh of course, we do this
and in the split of a second it's lots
of information but we process it very, very quickly.
But at the same time, I mean, it's not
like isolated cues but we are sort of taking
it all in, at the same time. I mean,
it's like several different cues that we process very
quickly. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. So that's, uh, um, like, uh, you
know, the, of course, uh, the, the result of
uh this uh uh process is uh extremely impressive,
as you said in the um in, in a
few uh tens or hundreds of milliseconds. So we
are capable of, you know, not exactly exactly who
you are, what you're doing and what's your relationship
with another? If you think about it, it's pretty
impressive. Now, the question again is how the brain
does it. So we are uh a little bit
uh uh like farther away from an answer to
this question for tourism. As I said, like we
know a lot about face perception and body perception
and biological motion perception. And that's a good basis
I think to start this enterprise of, you know,
understanding how we understand our complex social world. But
uh um you know, there are questions that are
because of course, understanding what the others are doing
and how they relate to each other also requires
to understand what they, what they have in mind,
to understand their goals, their intention, their motivations and
uh uh these, these questions fall under the big
umbrella of social cognition, um social neuroscience. And uh
this is a very young enterprise. We have begun
asking this question uh a few years ago and
uh there is a lot of effort and a
lot of energy, a lot of resources now that
are dedicated to this kind of research, mostly because
it's clear that uh um the society that we
are building, that we have built and that we
are building relies on our ability to manage people,
to organize a group of people, to understand how
people relate to each other. So to be able
to sustain this kind of social environment that we
live in, we have to understand as much as
we can about the human social brain. But uh
again, this is a very young uh enterprise. And
so most of the questions are still open to,
to discussion.
Mhm Right. So, and since we're talking here also
about the brain, of course, um And we are
referring mostly to spatial information, spatial cues, they are
processed of course by the visual system. And is
it the case that socially relevant spatial relations are
represented visually differently than stimuli that are just unrelated
or appear unrelated to one another?
Yeah, absolutely. So this is basically the uh one
of the main findings of our research in the,
in the recent years. Uh So, uh as I
said, we have first uh uh found uh uh
initial evidence in our, in our empirical data and
our empirical results suggesting that uh uh facing individuals,
which is our, which is a proxy of social
interacting individuals. So when I say facing, I'm implying
that this positioning is somehow suggesting to our brain
that these two people are interacting. And this is
why it's so important for our brain. So as
I said, we have found that facing individuals are
processed uh uh more efficiently than the very same
individuals uh in, in a different special relation. And
uh uh we have begun to show that uh
the very specialized mechanism that uh we have learned
to appreciate in perception, also apply to this configuration
of seemingly interacting bodies, so face to face bodies.
And uh uh and then we have found that
I use a lot of uh functional MRI, which
is a neuroimaging methodology that allows to record the
brain at work while it's working. So to look
into the brain uh uh to measure the brain
activity during um any kind of cognitive task. And
uh so using F MRI, we have seen that
visually in the visual areas. So in the areas
dedicated to face body, biological motion perception, the very
same bodies. So the two the two bodies, the
very same bodies are processed differently when they are
face to face, relative to when they're back to
back. And this is pretty impressive because uh so
we just had a similar with the two bodies
either positioned face to face or identically just flipped
so that they look back to back. So from
a visual viewpoint, these two stimuli carry exactly the
same information. The same amount of information is exactly
the same number of pixels, the same body shapes,
the same postures, the same color brightness, all the
visual information that you think of. But just the
fact that they are face to face, their positioning,
to face each other or facing away from each
other drives all kinds of different different effects in
the visual cortex. So for instance, the visual cortex
and in general, the level of activity in the
areas for face and body perception is significantly higher.
So the regions respond more when the bodies are
face to face, relative to when the two people
are back to back, which is already I think
very interesting. But also, uh for instance, uh we
have found using more sophisticated analytic methods uh on
uh uh uh F MRI data that uh the
representation of each individual body is more accurate. So
the brain represent each individual body better if the
body appears in a relation in a social relation
with another than when the body is presented in
isolation. So yeah, the the the short answer is
that yes, there is something special and when I
say special, I mean face like special in a
sense. And so as I said repeatedly uh is
like a face perception is the gold standard of
the efficiency of human visual perception. And so what
we see is that some of these very efficient
mechanisms that we have evolved developed to process faces
are used to process interacting people.
And so still about perception that there's something very
specific that I haven't asked you about yet. So
what is body form and body motion perception? And
in what ways exactly do these specific kinds of
perception contribute to processing social events?
So uh these are uh body but form and
body motion are the two fundamental component of the
visual system uses to build representation of an action.
So to understand another's action, so what another person
for instance is doing but it is true also
for the action of animals and also for the
movements of objects we need to extract mentioned about
their structure. So for instance, in the case of
a person, um how the various body parts are
positioning with respect to each other. So if the
hand is here or here, this defines a different
body posture, so a different body shape. So this
is the body form um information and then there
is the other side that is the motion. So
how the position of each part changes from time
to time and this defines the motion pattern. So
these are two different aspects that then they are
integrated. So these are the body form and our
body shape and the body motion uh are dissociated
different uh different processes. Uh ALSO because they are
um uh implemented, they are computed in different parts
in different brain regions. So we know that these
are two different aspects. But of course, the regions
that care about the body motion and the regions
that care about body shape work uh in sync
work really like in a close interaction with each
other. We say that they are functionally connected because
the information needs to be integrated to deliver the
representation of an action of an action, which is
the beginning of the process for action understanding. So
we first need to understand the body posture, the
body motion. And from there, we can start all
the inferential processes that allow us to understand what
the other, what the other's action goal is, uh
what the intention of the others are. And this,
this is what we call the social inference.
By the way body form and body motion perception
are these in any way forms of embodied cognition.
So, um no, these are visual processes. So the
idea of embodied cognition, the general idea of embodied
cognition is that uh uh much of our cognitive
life depends on our uh experience in the environment.
So it's based on in particularly impact in particular
our motor experience. So uh but when I talked
about the body uh form and body motion, I
was referring to visual processes like the processing tool
to extract information uh from the physical structure of
the of the of the input. Now does our
experience, our experience, our action, motor experience in the
environment affects the way in which we process other
actions and the social interactions. So we know that
uh of course, like we uh we are in,
we are in bodies like the brain is integrated
in a body that has a certain type of
experience. And the the way like our history of
interaction, the environment affects how we perceive other actions.
There is a very rich and complex literature on
this, you know, relationship between action, understanding and the
mo motor experience. We know much less about how
our experience of social interaction, so of interacting with
others affect the way in which we understand others,
social interactions. I I think there is no, there
is no really like a fully developed line of
research yet on this. But uh you know, like
uh uh there are a number of nontrivial questions
to ask. For instance, the idea is that when
I observe and others perform another, performing an action
in order to understand that's the basic idea of
embodiment to understand what the other is doing. I
need to sort of use this as simulation process.
I have to internally simulate the same action and
this allows me to understand what the others is
doing. But now in the context of social interaction,
I'm observing two people or more people interacting with
each other. So how does the motor simulation work
like can we simulate multiple actions at the same
time? So there are more people interacting. Our motor
system is busy at you know, simulating all these
actions like simultaneously. We are not sure the motor
system can do it. We we are not sure
the motor system can hold the representation of multiple
motor programs at the same time. And uh oh
you know, we can think oh maybe the the
the visual system selects the most important the more
of two agents. And this is what it follows
that there is research that shows that we are
very good at detecting in an interaction, who is
the agent and who is the patient. So who
is the one who is acting on the other?
And so maybe, and we know that um the
the system, the brain privileges information about agents. So
one possibility is that the motor simulation also privileges
the simulation of the action of the person who
is recognized as the agent. But again, these are
all possible solutions. But uh we don't know the
answer yet,
but at least potentially there's some space for embodied
cognition here.
Oh, there is always a space for embodied cognition.
It's a, it's a um it's a very interesting
uh uh uh angle to look at how uh
human cognition in general, like by you know, relating
the mind and the brain to the rest of
the body. This is absolutely interesting because as I
said cognition doesn't happen in a vacuum. We are
in a body and what happens to our body
certainly affects our brain and our mind. But uh
I'm also, I also have a very critical view
of embodied cognition because uh I think there are
a lot of things, a lot of representations that
don't depend on motor experience on our experience are
totally independent from the, from motor experience. And uh
so sometimes I tend to be a little bit
critical to the views that want to reduce the
whole human cognition to motor experience.
Mhm So now I have a couple of questions
that I think you've already at least slightly touched
on them earlier. But when it comes to social
representations is the social entity itself as important as
the relation that binds multiple entities together.
So, yeah, um I think the relation is uh
uh all that matters in uh in the social
life uh in uh in for social cognition. And
uh to the point that uh um when we
see when we perceive a relation between the two
social agents, between two people, uh we, the brain
creates a whole new representation that uh has almost
nothing to do with the two people itself. Like
what I mean? And we, we have, we have
shown it uh uh really like empirically. So um
when we see two objects, the neural response to
uh the two objects seen simultaneously is typically a
linear combination of the response to the two single
objects. So we can from, from the response to
the two objects together, we can retrieve information about
the two single object. Because the, the information about
the two single object is maintained in the representation
of this composite representation that involves both objects. So
if I see a pen and see if I
see these two objects, and I measure the response
to this first in the brain. And then I
measure the response to this in the brain. And
then I measure the response to them both presented
together. This response is typically an average of some
linear combination of the response to the two single
objects. But now what we see is that uh
when uh we see two people and these two
people are represented in a social interaction, the response
to these two people is a non linear combination
of the response to each individual body presented in
isolation. And this non linear combination of the response
to the individuals is an indication that the brain
is building a new representation that has almost nothing
to do with the individuals. And this new representation
is basically the, the the the core input for
the social cognition system. So yeah, the relation is
perhaps more important than the individuals themselves.
A and the relation is almost uh or perhaps
it is even a different entity or a different
kind of representation than the two individual people. And
even the two individual people interacting with one another.
I mean, it, it's a thing in and of
itself.
Right. Yes. Abso, that's, that's, again, that's, I was
too uh enthusiastic in my. Yes. But uh that's
my guess at the moment. Uh uh Yeah, it's
uh it's uh we have uh empirical data using
F MRI using electroencephalography that uh um uh can
isolate this integrative response that suggests that the brain
is transforming the input into into something that is
a new thing that has nothing to do with
the input itself. And we have seen this signature
of integration a lot when it comes to the
perception of interact, social, interacting people.
And when it comes to the brain, do we
know if there's actually visual specialization for diab human
human interactions? I mean is there a specialization for
that specifically or
not? Yeah, absolutely. As I said, we have recorded
using F MRI, we have recorded from visual cortex,
from visual regions and we have seen that there
are some very similar active parts of the visual
system that seems to like facing diets more than
anything else. So this is already one signature of
specialization we have seen even in behavioral task like
if we present stimuli around the perceptual threshold. So
in very low visibility conditions, so we are used
to do this experiment to isolate the limits of
visual perception. And so we present a stimuli, for
instance, low contrast stimuli very rapidly to the subject
and the subject have to report whether they have
seen a stimulus or not. And we see that
and this is one of the ways to measure
the efficiency of in the perception of a given
type of stimuli. And what we see is that
again, when we present these facing bodies, the system
is much faster. So the responses are much faster
and much more accurate than when present bodies in
isolation or in other kinds of special relations. So
we have a behavioral, we have F MRI, we
have ee electroencephalographic signature of that suggests that there
is a visual specialization for uh fishing diets. And
uh visual specialization means that uh we just have
uh uh very efficient mechanisms to detect this kind
of configuration in the space. So for instance, if
I present subjects with very clot, the rich and
noisy visual scene that has a tool facing people
somewhere in this scene, we have seen that subjects
immediately find these stimulus in the in the clutter.
And this is again another signature of the visual
efficiency.
So earlier, we've talked about the kinds of cues
that people process in looking at the social scene
and interpreting it as for example, when looking at
the diet of people as interacting or non interacting.
But how do we go from spatial relations between
people to uh perhaps trying to extract some information
about the kind of relationship they have with one
another and how much information can we extract from
them uh about that.
So, as I said, unfortunately, I cannot give you
an answer about how, because we are just at
the beginning of this enterprise. So maybe in a
few years, we'll be able to know how we
go from, you know, putting together. So the visual
system knows that the two people are face to
face, they are closing space, they are touching each
other, maybe uh they are, they have outstretched limbs
toward each other. So they have all these features.
So immediately the visual system um uh represents OK,
this might be a social interaction. And so this
information package is put is sent into the, you
know, high level networks for social inference, the so
called social brain network. And from here, how do
we come to understand for instance that these two
people are two lovers, for instance, or our two
enemies are competing? It's less clear what I can
say is that again, we are very sensitive to
small v in the spatial temporal patterns. So for
instance, the way in which one object moves with
respect to another can be immediately interpreted as having
a positive or negative intention. So and you know,
if you just a small acceleration in the movement
of an object relative to another object can suggest
that one is chasing the other or that the
one. So it's one that is chasing the other
or that the other is escaping from the other
like in small variation in the acceleration, for instance,
can give a completely different cognitive representation, mental representation
of what we see. But again, the computational uh
machinery that does this from, you know, seeing bodies
faces facing each other, especially close to understand the
the rich nature of a social interaction. That's really
an open question.
And do we have a good idea of what
of what are the areas of the brain that
are part of the network that that processes processes
social information.
Yeah, I mean, we do. Um SO definitely there
is a uh an important contribution of visual areas.
As I said, we have been discussing this so
far, like uh visual areas, extract of a lot,
a lot of of useful information for social inference.
And um and uh I I'd say that uh
because of the importance of uh the social life
from our survival, we have developed a number of
very efficient mechanisms to do so. So visual mechanism
dedicated to uh extract the socially radical information. But
then uh uh outside the the visual system, the
visual system is just the entry of the information
in the brain and outside of the visual information
in the brain. But then outside the visual system,
there, there is no one network, there are many
networks that uh uh implement processes that are relevant
for uh social cognition. For instance, the action understanding
network is the network dedicated it one and the
action and what understanding and action means means, understand
the goals and intentions of an action. There is
uh the, the mind or the mentalis network, which
is another set of regions that is dedicated to
what we call mind reading, what's in another mind,
what the others are thinking also, we are very
good at that and we don't know how that
happens. And um and uh uh then there is,
of course, the semantic system, the conceptual system that
represent all the knowledge that we have about the
others. And in particular, the social knowledge seems to
be a very specific type of knowledge that is
represented probably in dedicated part of the larger semantic
system. So yeah, uh what we need to understand
is really the specific computation in each of these
regions and also how the information travels within these
networks and how this network uh networks interact with
each other. Let me just add the la last
thing uh I talked a lot about visual information,
socially relevant visual information because that's what I study.
But you know, there is there, there is not
just vision, there are other sensory modalities and the
other sensory modalities carry also a lot of relevant
information for social cognition. Uh As we talked about
briefly about the speech, the acoustic signal, there's nothing
more social speech. And uh the smell is another
um field that uh is um uh is is
receiving a lot of attention uh because it's probably
one of the fundamental uh uh foundations of it
provides some foundations to uh social relationships. So it's
um it's a, it's a long, it's gonna be
a long way.
Yeah, of course, it's important to mention that, that
we here today were we were focusing on spatial
relations and on visual information because that's the main
focus of your research. But of course, we do
not only process visual information but also information from
the other senses when interacting with other people.
It's important to, to, to, to say so, so
not just because it's fair for our colleagues who
don't study vision, but also because uh vision is
one of the most if not the most studied
aspect of the human brain. Uh And some believe
that vision is also the main sensory modality for
humans. Uh Some agree, some don't agree with that,
but it's true that we are, we have a
representation of the brain that is very much centered
on visual processing. But it's uh it's uh it's
fair to acknowledge that, you know, there are other
important modalities and in fields of research that needs
to be acknowledged.
Of course. So let's get into our last topic
slash questions. So we've been focusing on humans here.
But what about the nonhuman animals? Because I mean,
we as people, I guess that we also look
at the spatial relations, body configurations of other animals.
And for example, there are some biped animals and
some quadrupeds as well. So do we distinguish in
specific ways between those two? And how does that
work? Uh ON the level of the brain neurologically?
So there are two aspects of this research. I'm
trying to answer them both. The first one is
uh our perception of other animals that are nonhumans.
Uh So, um uh the mechanism that I described
the first general answer to the question is that
all the mechanism that I described so far uh
like this ability to process phases, biological motion bodies.
So this is why I talk about faces, biological
motion, bodies, bodies and not human bodies, not human
faces, non human motion, because these especially individual cortex,
the regions that cares about this, that care about
this important aspect of the social life, recognizing faces,
bodies, motion um operate over uh any animate entity.
So they don't seem to care much whether a
face is a human face or a monkey face.
For instance, the fusiform face area, which is the
region that responds to phases that has this very
strong selective response to phases, doesn't show very reliable
difference between a human face and a monkey phase
or a cat phase. And the same is for
the regions that process motion, they process biological motion.
So any kind of motion that looks like the
property of a biological motion relative to mechanic motion.
But uh uh they don't have much uh you
know, fine uh fine grain distinctions in terms of,
you know, uh the the species that is uh
moving, whether it's a human or not. So, you
know, uh one line of research, we really asked
the question, whether the visual system really doesn't help
at all in the distinction between a human and
nonhuman animals, which is very important us, I mean,
we need to know whether and animating is a
human is a conspecific or not. And we were
very, I was very particularly surprised by the research
on biological motion because it was a little bit
confusing, like most of the field was talking about
biological motion, but some authors were talking about, you
know, these regions being tuned to human motion. So
I wanted to see whether they are really tuned
to human motion, which means that these regions are
capable of distinguishing what is human from what is
non human. Or in fact, they are picking up
some feature in the motion that is typical of
humans, but they don't really what is a human
and what is a nonhuman thing. So the intuition,
the idea that we had was OK, we can
uh uh present videos of uh uh four kind
of animate entities. A walking man, just a human
who walks another human, a baby crawling uh cat,
pa four legs crawling and uh a cat is
a nonhuman which also walks uh uh with, with
four legs and a cheek. A chika is a
non human but like the prototypical human walks with
two legs. So we wanted to see whether the
regions in the visual cortex that care about motion
could really distinguish human from no human. In which
case we should, we should, we should see that
response to the man and the baby is more
similar than the response to the cat and the
chicken or they are not really human uh preferring
regions, but they actually only care about motion. And
so what they can distinguish is the kind of
motion and they don't care whether it's a human
or nonhuman. And because there are these two big
categories of motion, bipedal motion, which is typical of
the human species, but not only of the human
species and quadrupedal motion. We predicted that if these
regions are only about the kind of motion, we
should find that the response to the man is
more similar to the response to the cheek because
they are both bipedal and the response to the
cat is more similar to the neural response to
the baby because these are two quadrupeds, they are
moving with four legs and this is exactly what
we found. So this means that yes, what what
this means is that yes, the visual system uh
is capable of making distinctions a subtle distinction. In
this case, in the type of motion, which might
be useful then to distinguish what is a human
from a nonhuman, but they are not yet representations
of humanness, the visual system doesn't seem to care
much about humanness, it cares about animated things, animals,
whatever is a biological entity. Of course, you can
find the differences. Uh FOR instance, uh because, you
know, I don't wanna, you know, his colleagues to
jump and say no, but uh also, you know,
like uh the response to human faces, individual system
is stronger. But then it becomes hard to know
whether it is just an effect of familiarity because
we see a lot of human faces and we
have seen very few monkey faces in our life.
So you can pick up this difference due to
the familiarity of the stimulus to which the visual
system is very sensitive. But it doesn't mean that
uh uh intrinsically the visual system care about the
human on human distinction.
Uh And I guess that uh one very interesting
thing about studying these, about the brain processes, information,
I mean motion information and spatial uh uh and
the information about the body and spatial relationship uh
relations between humans and nonhumans is that this also
might also inform us about if about whether specific
areas of the brain specialized for processing human related
information or if they are perhaps more domain general
and they are specialized just for motion or for
particular body configurations or something like that. Right.
Yeah. So the kind of manipulation that I described
where we manipulated the motion in the bipedal versus
quadrupedal human versus non human is one example of
the kind of manipulation that we do. And this
is why it's fun to be an experimentalist because
you know, we have the brain and the brain
activity, but then we have to read the information
in that activity. So we can use this kind
of manipulation to see. OK, what's in that activity?
What's information in that activity is information about the
species a human versus non human is information about
uh uh motion. So by pedal versus quadrupedal. And
so in this way, exactly with this manipulation, we
found that in fact, these regions in the visual
cortex really care about motion. That's all they care
about. But there are other regions in a higher
level in higher order systems that uh instead begin
to make the distinction between a human and a
human because our cognition needs to make that distinction.
Great. So, uh Doctor Pape, just before we go,
would you like to tell people where they can
find you and your work on the internet?
Yes. So I have a website, a personal website
uh uh V uh uh sorry dot I'm learning
French. So it's
like that's
OK. It's, it's terrible. So VVV uh dot Lua
pao.com, I'm also active on Twitter as a Ya
um P. Uh uh I have recently joined this
uh Blue Sky uh platform now website, uh which
is uh which is gathering a lot of, you
know, scientists around the world uh where we have
very interesting discussions and uh uh or you can
always reach me by email. My email addresses are
available my, my, my uh my website and my
institutional website.
Great. So I'm leaving links to all of that
in the description box of this interview. And thank
you so much again for taking the time to
come on the show. It's been a pleasure to
talk to you. My
pleasure and thanks for having me again.
Hi, everyone. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you like what I'm doing, please
consider supporting the show on Patreon or paypal. You
can find the links in the description box down
below. And if you like the interview, please share
it, leave a like hit the subscription button and
comment. The show is brought to you by N
Lights learning and development and differently check their website
at N lights.com. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters, Pero Larson, Jerry Mueller and Frederick Sunder
Bernard. So all of Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whittenberg
are no wolf, Tim Hollis, Eric Aleni J Connors
Philip Forrest Connelly. Then the mere Robert Winde ruin.
Nai Z Mark Nevs Colin hope Mikel Storm, Sam
Andre Francis for Agns Fergal Ken Har Hero Michel,
Jonathan lebron Jars and Eric Heinz, Mark Smith. Tom
Hummels are friends, David Wilson, dear Ruben, Ro Romani
Charlotte, Bli, Nicola Barbaro, Adam hunt Palo Stassi Nele
Bach Guy, Madison, Gary G. Hellman, Samo Zal Adrian
Yi Paul Tolentino, Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Bruner
Douglas Fray, Franco, Beto Lotti Gabriel Pan Cortez or
Lalit Scott Zachary Fish. Tim Duffy and Smith John
Wiesman, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georgina, L lo
A George the off Chris Williams and Peter W
David Williams Di Costa Anton Erickson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shower, Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, bungalow atheists Larry D
Lee junior, Old Harri Bon, Starry Michael Bailey. Then
Sperber, Robert Grass is Jeff mcmahon. Jake Zul Barnabas
Radix Mark Temple, Thomas Dubner, Luke Neeson, Chris to
Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica Nowicki Linda Brandon, Nicholas
Carlson, Ismael Bensley Man, George Katis, Valentin Steinman, Per
Rowley, Kate Von Goler, Alexander Robert Liam Donaway. Br
Masoud Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular, Jonas Hartner Ursula. Good enough
Gregory Hastings David Pins of Sean Nelson and Mike
Levine. A special thanks to my producers is our
web, Jim Frank Luca Stink. Tom Weeden, Bernard, Ni
Curtis Dixon Benedict Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick
Tobin John Carl Montenegro, Alick Ortiz and Nick Golden.
And to my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergi Adrian
Bogdan Knit and Rosie. Thank you for all.